il est 20 heures ici à montigny le
bretonneux le stress se fait ressentir
la proche du couvre-feu vélo bus
voitures chacun s'organise pour rentrer
chez soi avant 21h un tout petit peu
stressé à cause du couvre-feu on doit
tous être chez nous à ranteil north à ne
jamais oublier qu'on a des seins travail
en interne avec des heures de sport
du coup la journée c'est compliqué de
finir sa journée à 21h faut vraiment
être à une heure chez soi et si bas on
dépasse de quelques minutes on peut se
faire prendre
mais en soi c'est quand même une bonne
chose par rapport à aux virus qui
circulent parce que on sait quand même
que la contamination se fait dans les
soirées étudiantes surtout depuis ce
matin on se dit bon ce soir il faut
rentrer à 21h assez compliqué voilà faut
s'organiser ce qui compliquait parmi les
personnes touchées par le couvre-feu les
restaurateurs ici chez ceux kebab
dernier repas à 20h30 avant le baisser
de rideau à une centaine de mètres même
constat dans cet établissement de monti
le bretonneux
si d'ordinaire le samedi soir la
structure fait entre 40 et 50 couverts
ce premier samedi de couvre-feu
seulement une dizaine ont été servis on
va essayer calmes et développer un peu
l'emporter comme on l'a fait
ailleurs sur notre restaurant de
chavenay et mais malheureusement on sait
pas s'ils allaient gens ne viennent pas
en nous on dépend d'eux des clients et
s'il n'y a pas de client bat bat chiffre
d'affaires il est à désormais à 21h le
couvre feu a débuté il ya quelques
instants
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
les yvelinois jouent le jeu et les rues
sont désertes
on croise seulement des voitures sur la
route patrouille de voie publique et
opération le contrôle se sont organisés
objectif vérifiés les attestations de
dérogation elles permettent de circuler
dans l'espace public entre 21h et 6h du
matin pour des motifs impérieux de
famille pour des motifs de santé pour du
soin animale notamment donc en fait on
est en train de
de vérifier que chaque personne et son
attestation à partir du moment où vous
avez une mesure aussi importante que le
couvre-feu qui est mise en place ce qui
est des raisons sanitaires majeurs et
qu'il est important nécessaire de
montrer à la population que des
contrôles sont effectués pour que le
civisme soit constatée et là ce soir
nous le constatons avec enthousiasme le
non respect du couvre-feu entré une
contravention de 135 euros des nouvelles
mesures plutôt bien appliquée dans le
département